[Music]
when people think of tofu they think of
bland
weird
boring
it's just this
block that comes in a box
but tofu can be so much more than that
my name is paul ing i'm the owner of
fang on tofu shop my family business has
been around since 1933 and ultimately
making tofu is my life now we make about
500 pounds of tofu a day i guess i'm
lucky that i make the stuff that i love
to eat
[Music]
when i took over the family business
i had no knowledge of making tofu there
was lots of trial and error you know
even even now i have trial and error
because i'm still trying to perfect it
making tofu is like making cheese except
that you have to make the soy milk first
fresh tofu is made out of two
ingredients soybeans and water tofu
making is easy and hard at the same time
it's hard to make it taste good unless
you put your heart and soul into it
beans go into the grinder and water's
going through it so soy milk comes out
one spout while the pulp comes out
another spout so we go through hundreds
of pounds of soybeans a day it's heavy
stuff so it requires at least two people
to make
when the pulp comes out it comes into a
tank where there's already water in it
so that we can
sort of give it more water to extract
more soy milk that pulp needs to be
re-ground on the next grinder so the
goal in doing that is just to be more
efficient in extracting soy milk and
getting as much as we can
back when my grandfather started the
business they
hand ground the soybeans using a
stone grinder that they would
turn and circle around and around and
now when we make tofu compared to back
then
we can make tofu a hundred times faster
during the process i check with a
refractometer a refractometer measures
the amount of solids in water i want to
make sure that the quality of the soy
milk is at its peak now not necessarily
having really strong soy milk means
having great tofu it has to be the right
level of soy milk so when the soy milk
gets pumped out it looks like a bubble
bath and i suppose you know sitting in a
pool of soy milk but you know that's
maybe better left unsaid there's a lot
of foam in the production of soy milk
and i don't want any of it to go to
waste because there's potential in all
this stuff so we scoop up the foam into
buckets and then we load it into the
cooking vat just so that we get every
last drop of the soybean soy milk in
this raw condition cannot be
consumed
raw soy milk is not digestible
back in the day my grandfather used to
cook soy milk in a big walk i mean it
would take forever since you know it was
this huge wok and a small flame it took
three hours to get soy milk to boil
compared to what we do now takes it
about 15 minutes good soy milk is the
key to making
good tofu soy milk is the basic essence
of all soy products that you would see
so you can make
tofu out of it hard or soft you can make
drinking soy milk out of it you can make
tofu pudding out of it it's just the
essence of all it and the key is if it's
good
the difference between the tofu burning
and tofu blocks it's the same process
the same coagulant the same everything a
coagulant is something that turns it
into curds like much like you would make
cheese and you break it up
so the process of breaking up and making
tofu this part is still essentially the
same as it was has it ever been for
thousands of years imagine taking over a
tofu business and having no knowledge of
how to make tofu
i had to ask family members but family
members recollection of the recipes and
how to make stuff was kind of fuzzy they
would say a cup of this or a spoon of
that
i decided to have certain family members
do the physical process in front of me
to show me how to do it and even they
couldn't do it people always constantly
talk about tradition versus modern
technology
recreating recipes at home in the small
setting versus a production level is
quite different when people think of
machines they think that it's an
automated system but it's not it's quite
still mechanical the machines at least
what we use
so it requires a person to
to make sure that the quality of the soy
milk coming out that makes the tofu is
good the strength of it how much water
that we're asking how fine the grind is
all this is
why it's important that the person who
makes the tofu cares about it
i'm the type of person who if i do
something i have to care about it if i
don't care about it then i shouldn't do
it
there were many things that i didn't
quite like about the old business
basically there were lots of pitfalls in
the technology at the time the press
that we use is a pneumatic press and it
gives exactly precisely 75 pounds of
pressure back in the old days they used
anything and everything they could
possibly use to press the tofu there was
either bricks rocks or sacks of rice now
we use fabricated molds especially made
for tofu making but back in the day when
my grandfather was making it they used
whatever they could and most often was a
soda crate the soda crate had exactly
the precise squares necessary to make
tofu soda crates were made out of wood
and obviously after a while with water
and everything would warped it wasn't
that long where they would have to
replace it pretty constantly it took
quite a while to get like a hundred
blocks of tofu because they were
literally pressing one block of tofu at
a time now to make 100 blocks of tofu
would probably take
20 minutes
[Music]
the person who's making the tofu is
important because
the other person decides whether that
consistency was good or it was done
right
makes a world of difference you have
fern tofu you have soft tofu how firm
how soft is the person making it
tofu is a blank slate you know you can
do whatever you want
the difference between the person who
really loves making tofu and just the
worker doing it is that tofu is going to
taste better to the person eating the
tofu
my kids actually
love the tofu pudding well
one kid loves it there's always the
hater
with the tofu pudding we want a very
smooth delicate texture you don't
disturb you just pour and let it sit and
form it's still quite traditional in how
it's made
when we scoop the tofu pudding in front
of people it's the traditional way of
serving it you look in and you see the
tofu pudding it's literally being
scooped for them like like ice cream
the act of scooping for someone is
almost like a performance there is a way
of doing this not just any old way you
have to scoop it in thin little layers
or else you would create too much water
from scooping too deeply
tofu pudding eaten the traditional way
at least for us
is just the tofu pudding with a brown
sugar syrup on top in chinese it's
called the tofu flour you know like
something delicate
[Music]
my family business has been around for
87 years since 1933. there was obviously
immense family pressure how to be and
what to do and the products to make
they were
really looking for me to extend the
legacy of the family business
[Music]
making tofu is my life now
sometimes it's lost on me on why
i'm doing this you know running the
family business and carrying the
tradition of making tofu is a real
challenging and difficult path
yeah i mean i questioned myself why do i
do this day after day
to make my family proud
sort of doesn't make great tofu
yeah possibly
but the biggest reason i do this
is to support my kids and my family
[Music]
you